[Música]
bienvenidos a esta crónica de ciencia y
tecnología soy valentina torres anchas y
es un gusto acompañarlos de nuevo en
medio de la guerra que vive ucrania uno
de los principales temores en materia de
conectividad es que rusia ha bombardeado
infraestructuras de comunicaciones en
esa nación lo que en diferentes lugares
ha provocado el corte y la conexión a
internet en este contexto y lo hemos que
el fundador de tesla envió un conjunto
de antenas para que el país pueda
conectarse a su servicio de internet
satelital starling pero en qué consiste
este sistema en france 24 conversamos
con su amigo stephane experto en
tecnología es un sistema de internet de
banda ancha de digamos de velocidades
altas a través de una red de satélites
que la compañía ha lanzado al espacio y
que a los cuales básicamente las antenas
se conectan y desde ella funciona muy
similar a cómo funciona el internet en
tu casa pones un wifi y tienes internet
en tu zona y la mosca también es
fundador de la compañía espacial spacex
y este sistema de internet satelital fue
creado para proveer una conexión de
banda ancha
es decir de alta velocidad generada con
antenas que se conectan a satélites
principalmente para proporcionar
internet a zonas rurales donde es
difícil garantizar una conexión
tradicional del problema del internet de
alta velocidad en el mundo es que tú
puedes llevar internet de alta velocidad
hoy en día a la mayoría de los centros
urbanos grandes a las ciudades grandes
pero los sitios rurales si en los sitios
apartados es muy costoso llevar internet
y el internet que hay hoy en día digamos
satelital no es muy bueno y estos son
unos satélites pequeños unos satélites
que están en la órbita baja del planeta
cierto y de acuerdo con lo que hemos
visto técnicamente la compañía entonces
la información baja y sube a velocidades
que si se cuentan tal hogar como arantxa
para una persona que está en un sitio
remoto o donde no haya alguien que pueda
llegar y conectarle una fibra óptica
para darle internet digamos a unas
velocidades apropiadas este servicio aún
no está disponible en todo el planeta la
compañía ya ha lanzado más de 2.000
satélites y tiene permiso para ubicar 12
mil en la órbita baja de la tierra sin
embargo ya solicitó permiso a las
autoridades para que en total sean
30.000 y se garantice una conexión
global con los ataques rusos a ucrania
nos envió 50 antenas para que en
diversas poblaciones haya conexión a
internet satelital y anunció una segunda
carga de estos productos un cráneo se ha
quedado sin internet y muchos de los
accesos que tenían que venían digamos
desde rusia fueron bloqueados entonces
un poco la oferta de hilos más pesada
que vamos a enviarles más antenas para
que puedan poner en diferentes ciudades
y puedan conectar a la gente a saber qué
está pasando a estar informados a poder
comunicarse entre sí etcétera etcétera
ya empezando a funcionar claramente ahí
hay unos riesgos asociados a esto y es
que yo puedo saber dónde están las
antenas digamos el gobierno ruso podría
saber dónde están las antenas entonces
también y las manos que sacó un
comunicado un punto en estos días que se
oiga traten de no dejar las antenas muy
visibles traten de que no se vean pues
porque si uno sabe que las antenas están
ahí quiere decir que hay cerca hay uno
hay un grupo poblacional grande y podría
ser un objetivo militar
cambiamos de tema porque el mobile world
congress una de las ferias tecnológicas
más importantes del mundo regresó de
manera presencial tras dos años a
barcelona después de la pandemia además
de los grandes nombres de compañías
asiáticas o americanas como samsung o
amazon la presencia de pabellones
latinoamericanos dejó claro que la
región avanza en el ecosistema digital
veamos el informe del issga single y
mount botín
en la feria mundial de los móviles de
este año la presencia latinoamericana se
hizo notar la delegación colombiana es
la más importante en número de
participantes con más de 40 empresas del
sector tecnológico la obra corre a
promocionar una de ellas especializada
en desarrollo y animación 3d su compañía
pretende potenciar su presencia en el
mercado mundial este es el cuarto año
que venimos finalmente la empresa está
en un proceso de internacionalización
buscando más clientes en otros
continentes y esto nos permite crecer
como empresa y mostrarle al mundo que
nuestro talento es de talla mundial la
apuesta colombiana da resultados en 2021
sus exportaciones en tecnología
crecieron más de 40 por ciento hoy
representan 3% del pib tres veces más
que el sector del café en el pabellón de
brasil los empresarios también notan más
interés internacional dedicada al
acompañamiento de compañías en su
transformación digital esta empresa no
dudó en acudir al evento
parte de ese movimiento de
transformación digital entonces también
en representación de una empresa nacida
y desarrollada en un país en
latinoamérica no sentimos que aporta ese
sentido de diversidad y de apoyo por su
parte chile índigo por primera vez a la
exposición de este año con 8 startups
tecnológicas como esta una herramienta
de formación y simulación con realidad
inmersiva trabajar con poco continente
también ayuda a mejorar el desarrollo de
su actividad trabajamos en chile- mucho
con minería con gran minería acá en
españa por ejemplo con mercedes benz
españa es nuestro cliente para que te
hagas una idea de clientes muy
diferentes pero esa diversidad mejora
los resultados también de los
entrenamientos porque tienes distintas
categorías o tipos de simulaciones que
tú puedes crear en latinoamérica sigue
creciendo en el ecosistema tecnológico
mundial según un estudio reciente su
inversión en el sector aumentada casi 10
por ciento de este año con este panorama
alentador las delegación latinas pueden
aumentar su representación en el mobile
world congress de 2023
y finalizamos con un robot que fue
presentado durante este evento se trata
de un androide barman desarrollado por
la empresa macro robotics que utiliza
tecnología 5g para preparar y servir
jugos vinos o cócteles y que atendió a
muchos de los asistentes al evento kim
como fue llamado el androide habla
varios idiomas y ofrece recomendaciones
asimismo cuenta con reconocimiento
facial por lo que puede recordar y
reconocer a quienes ya ha atendido para
brindar una atención más personalizada
así llegamos al final de este espacio a
ustedes muchas gracias por su sintonía
continúen con nosotros en france 24
[Música]